evelyne courtecuisse responsable du
secours catholique chevreuse magny les
hameaux toussus le noble est à présent
d'invités du 7-8 bons scores sur ce
plateau nous allons découvrir avec vous
les cafés du jeudi à partir du 16 mai
toutes les semaines tous les jeudis vous
allez proposer ce rendez-vous à magny
les hameaux salle coluche au pôle
plaisent blaise pascal comment cela va
se dérouler tout simplement chacun
viendra parler de ce qu'il veut oui tout
à fait en fait ce sera tout simple on a
simplement prévu on va dire la
logistique de café les petits gâteaux et
puis chacun peut venir
tout le monde est bienvenu et en fait il
s'agit simplement de créer des contacts
entre les personnes de leur de permettre
à des personnes peut-être de connaître
leurs voisins qui sont nouveaux qui ne
connaissent pas à ces nouveaux de
s'intégrer un petit peu dans leur
quartier
donc voilà chacun vient il n'y a pas de
thème particulier le but d'helton pour
la solitude en fait tout simplement elle
a tout à fait c'est de rompre la
solitude et puis aussi de trouver des
moyens de faire en sorte que les gens
puissent s'entraîner avec nous on puisse
les aider aussi bien sûr en tant que
bénévole du secours catholique on a
aussi un rôle à jouer là-dedans bien sûr
le premier rendez vous ce sera le 16 mai
ensuite ce sera tous les jeudis c'est un
rendez-vous qui existe déjà sur une
commune voisine celle de tous su comment
ça s'est passé
oui alors en fait à tous eu le contexte
est un petit peu différente c'est une
commune qui s'est développé assez
rapidement il ya il ya quelques années
et donc beaucoup de nouveaux arrivants
ce qui fait que c'était réellement un
besoin pour ces nouveaux arrivants de se
rencontrer donc ça a démarré il ya à peu
près trois ans avec des mamans qui se
rencontraient à la sortie de l'école
du coup maintenant il ya une vingtaine
de personnes qui se rencontrent
régulièrement ça tourne
l échange j'irai des petits services des
conseils
elles discutent des problèmes
d'éducation des enfants parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça va au delà des
discussions justement en guise les
différentes mamo qui est qui participent
en tout cas surtout une noble on verra
la population qui se rendra sur manie
les mots oui ça va au-delà aujourd'hui
on échange des services tout est fermé
entre le fait par exemple ben voila un
petit service pour garder les enfants
une personne qui bat qui voilà qui sait
pas faire c'est au tour d'une led rideau
ben voilà on se on apporte la machine à
coudre et on lui montre comment faire
voilà ce genre de chose sinon c'est très
demandé d de l'entr'aide j'aimerais
juste une petite parenthèse est ce que
vous regrettez que ce genre de rendez
vous que vous instaurez sur les
différentes communes soit aujourd'hui
devenu presque obligatoire pour
continuer à créer ce lien social
aujourd'hui les gens n'aillent peu les
uns vers les autres quel regard vous
portez sur ça disons que ce soit que ce
soit obligatoire
je ne sais pas il faut bien lieu il faut
bien il faudrait un lieu et un moment ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer que les gens
s'échangent des services sans qu'existe
ce rendez vous que vous mais je pense
que ça ça se fait un petit peu mais
aujourd'hui on les gens quand même
beaucoup tendance à se replier sur eux
mêmes
peut-être simplement parce qu'ils ont
des problèmes et il imagine pas que
simplement d'en parler ça peut les aider
à les résoudre et de la même façon le
ils ont peut-être des choses à apporter
ils se rendent pas compte de ce qu'ils
peuvent avoir à apporter aux autres
aussi et donc je crois que créer des
lieux comme ça ça peut permettre ça en
fait c'est l'une des principales
missions du secours catholique c'est ce
qui rend beau lise lemieux l'action du
secours catholique association à but non
lucratif qui existe depuis 1946 mon but
est justement de de régler les problèmes
de pauvreté d'exclusion cherché à
promouvoir la justice sociale
oui c'est au café et est en fait
d'accompagner les personnes en
difficulté de façon à les aider à s'en
sortir par elle-même est en fait le but
n'est pas de faire pour eux mais voilà
mais de les aider à s'en sortir et je
pense que c'est une façon de le faire
aussi au travers de
de ces lieux de rencontre comme les
cafés bars et les cafés du jeudi ça
débute le 16 mai si vous êtes sur la
ville de magny les hameaux d'ailleurs ce
sera ouvert uniquement aux résidents de
magny les hameaux
non pas du tout ouvert aux résidents pas
du tout non on a tous eu en fait quand
on dit a tous eu il ya aussi les gens de
châteaufort jeu juste pour vous corriger
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de
chevreuse oui en fait ces châteaux forts
tous humani voilà et donc s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui déjà aux gens de château
fort et même de manier mais évidemment
avec la distance s'est pas forcément
évident bon et puis on l'a on l'a ouvert
dans le quartier de l'hôtel de ville où
il ya quand même pas mal chevaux
d'allemagne et où il ya déjà pas mal de
monde mais c'est ouvert à tous ceux qui
n'y a pas besoin de s'inscrire via queen
chacun vient hélas tout le temps qu'il
veut parce qu'il ya un créneau entre 9h
et 11h30 voilà si on veut venir 15 ans
rien aux heures et si on veut rester
toute la matinée on assure que la
matinée secours catholique service de
l'église catholique est ce qu'il ya un
lien avec la religion aussi lors de ces
différents rendez vous pas du tout
puisque enfin pas du tout qu'il fallait
bien un lien dans le sens où les
bénévoles du secours catholique bien sûr
fond ça danse était voilà le fond dans
cet esprit bien sûr mais par contre
c'est on s'adresse à tout le monde et on
a c'est pas un lieu pour parler de
religion voilà j'en reviens donc à ce
café qui se tiendra pour la première
fois à magny les hameaux qui va se
charger de l'animé de l'organiser alors
aujourd'hui nous sommes une dizaine de
bénévoles sur sur le groupement donc
nous serons trois ou quatre à venir
l'animé un petit peu chacune tour et
puis où chacune ou chacun d'ailleurs
quelques fois et donc il y aura toujours
au moins deux bénévoles de l'équipe qui
sont les sujets sont abordés tout tabou
sur le dakar vient avec l'exécution
qu'il soit pilote à bord on fera ce
qu'on pourra voir animer tout ça juste
pour conclure peut-être un bilan de vos
activités justement sur sur cette
antenne sur ces trois communes que vous
chapeauté oui écouter ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que nos activités actuellement sur
sur les trois communes dont on a parlé
du café de tous eu il ya aussi un
accueil qui se fait dans le cadre
à manille les amours au centre social où
on accueille des personnes qui ont des
difficultés qui qu'on peut écouter
accompagner apporter des aides
matérielles financières ou simplement
des aides dans des démarches
administratives ou autres
donc ça je dirais par exemple en 2012 on
a accueilli à peu près une cinquantaine
de familles qu'on a aidé de différentes
façons en lien avec les assistent les
assistantes sociales
et puis on est aussi en lien avec les
autres associations caritatives premier
café donc à magny les hameaux qui a fait
du jeudi le 16 mai merci à vous qu elle
sera ensuite chaque semaine est
différente coordonnées se sont affichés
si vous souhaitez en savoir plus bien
évidemment et ça reprendra en septembre
voilà merci pour cette précision